le nouveau centre de calcul du cnes a
été installé dans un bel ensemble
fonctionnel de bâtiment carré de 42 sur
40 mètres relayée par une rotonde pour
un total de onze mille six cents mètres
carrés ton 4200 mètres carrés de salles
informatiques et des installations
équipe touristes
ça rend plus nécessaire surtout
enfin
quelle histoire
ou étrangers il s'agit aussi des données
des essais et lancement d'ariane mais
également des données d'orbites au
graphie des satellites
deux caractéristiques sont communes à
toutes ces données
le volume en est considérable il faut
être capable de les garder mais
également de les mettre à la disposition
des utilisateurs cette capacité de
stockage si impressionnante constitue la
véritable mémoire technologique et
scientifique du clair si vous cachez
derrière le terme noir le ps que c'est
un organisme vivant
la mémoire se rafraîchit se régénère a
aussi la cendre de souvenirs il est vrai
qu'en partie le cnes a créé sa mémoire
ce n'est pas uniquement ça quand même
c'est un lieu où tous les jours se font
de nouvelles choses se créent de
nouvelles choses
grâce à ces moyens de calcul je crois
aussi qu'il faut pas oublier tout ce
qu'on peut appeler les artères qui
viennent jusqu'à ce centre venant des
états unis de russie de différents coins
de france et où à partir de ces artères
de nombreuses personnes sur le
territoire français et étrangers ont
accès à cette noire donc c'est encore
quelque chose de très vivant donc ça
peut être une mémoire